yup
i'm just going to finish chewing on this
protein bar
i won't get into sure
protagonism
bob is back i repeat hey tony sent
master you're
always so early no i didn't mean 20
given away uh
69.99 as always what a memester
thank you tony you're a tough guy
you're generous guy
today bobby's back remember bob from
surgeon simulator
well they he was so popular that they
made a bob too
that's right insurgent simulator 2
out today or yesterday
uh excited to play this it's got co-op
so i'm gonna play with ken as soon as he
wakes up
as soon as he rolls out of bed
i bet he's just scrolling through right
now
doing his [ __ ] but you know what that
can't stop us
actually i know he's already out he's
downloaded the game let's say
bob together
in the sequel i'm ready
i'm the killers the ls the realest the
hundred dollar billis
i'll put gorillas and pillows and i put
the pillows
in the gorillas hey hey i just gotta do
i'mma [ __ ] you in the pool hey
that was a little freestyle holy [ __ ]
dude
here we go here we go
let's go yes they already nailed the
hand motion control
where's the tim is there a tambourine
here i gotta slap it
i already have this urge to slap [ __ ]
give me something to slap there it is
this is yeah [ __ ] you chair
i'm a ceo yeah that's how it's done
all right how do i grab oh i can move
the hand all right
so i grab it all right gotcha
we need a we need a key somewhere
perhaps it's in here yes
huh
that was dramatic ceo smacking
tambourines i'm right all right
okay where's the game
oh spray paint epic how do i spray with
it
oh you gotta shake it first
teething troubles with the doors i'm
afraid the unlock button
should be nearby where's the tambourine
let me in let me
ken are you there ride me on discord
please
i think i'm doing a tutorial yeah
this is a tutorial you should play
through this one all right so shift to
move your hand
oh i like this
excellent button pressing you're a
natural
that moment when your hand comes oh i
see i'm sitting sideways
damn they made improvements man
jelly hands be like yeah all right let
me get the broom
and we're on our merry and on our merry
way
a scope room we're gonna beat the game
together bro
i'm not just gonna let you go when it's
convenient you're coming
you're coming with me broom no matter
what
[ __ ] [ __ ] here we go
i am sorry about the mess don't worry
it's all good no problem
uh where am i going i need to do surgery
i'm a doctor please
requires
what does it say oh i did it thanks
broom you're a real pal
what should i name you ken your name is
ken
the broom you might you're my bestie i
love you
let's go
there we go oh there's my av card
[ __ ] i'm speed running this i know how
to do this
i'm good at games anyway
i'm dr pamela preston one of the
founders you'll be the very first to
trial our surgeon simulator training bro
do you guys not have audio yeah you do
okay
bruh can i eat the donut
[Music]
i think i that's how you eat right
the controls are actually surprisingly
intuitive i gotta all right i gotta
throw it in my mouth
delicious i love it
i kind of want to play this in vr in a
weird way but i'll probably barf all
over the place
they tend to leave like a little secrets
in there game something
gekko wacko
i work in surgery in real life so i
can't wait to see this
all right i'll show you how it's done
then
someone's i forgot about broom
my bestie come here
don't be scared don't be scared
i'm scared we're going through
come on bro
saw the vikings stormed the shores of
england
[ __ ] this way
this way i'm good at games
where am i it's teaching me how to jump
like i don't know how to jump
alright how do i jump maybe i need to
walk on broom
i'm gonna do it without jumping just to
spite the game
did it as i said it's a work in progress
do i need to break that glass i think
throw boom
this is so chaotic
this is how i wake up every day all
right broom i need
uh [ __ ] what do i do
maybe i jump over here oh sorry broom
you're coming with me
there will be no point in this game
without brooms i gotta
what is happening i'm doing surgery just
give me a sec
i'm always losing those things
uh the key card all right hey we got g
fuel nice
it's so satisfying oh oh god all right
i'm sorry
we got it we got this there it is oh
there it is there it is there it is
there it is come on my best friend chair
you're coming this
is bob bob is back
[Music]
all kinds of medical emergencies with
ease and confidence
i'm a professional exciting we'll start
your training with a quick heart
transplant a quickie don't show me i'll
walk you through it
it'll be a breeze oh i know how to do it
don't worry
i'm not sure why that door's locked
don't worry i mean
julian sharer is that door locked get
right in there
okay well i guess i'll have to come back
later
let's try something a little different
he's dying
i love him whoa what is happening why am
i flying
oh okay this is new
your jeep has been in transit for a
month what the hell okay
let's try this instead we're going to
attempt a leg transplant
oh yes leg yes
kiwi thank you for the fitty god damn me
it's a nice plan
ken kenko
all right leg transplant time bros
all right first of all gotta wash your
hands
that's step one of surgery gotta make
sure it's sanitary bros
[Music]
apparently we're out of water so we're
just gonna have to raw dog this soap
i am i'm looking at my own torso right
now
that's a bit disturbing all right i'm
into it
so shift you move your hand yeah
yeah yeah get that shot clean
all right we're clean right let's eat
the soap
all right we're clean i ate the serb
that gadget with the screen is a
diagnostic scanner it'll tell you what's
wrong with your patient
lesson one keep a close eye on bob's
blood level
if he bleeds out it's game over
oh they're bro bob's got a dodgy right
leg
[Music]
i missed you so much i miss you so much
but
rip his right leg off and put it in the
chute what
tickle tickle yeah that's right who's my
bobby
yeah you're tickling tickly wiggly oh
don't worry i'm clean i'm clean bob
i'm clean we gotta cure him
rip his right leg off and put it in the
chute
oh the right leg oh i almost tore off
the wrong leg that would have been
embarrassing don't worry bob
here i'll hold your hand through this
all right you can't rip off his hands
i'll rip his leg up how would it it
would just come off will it
[Applause]
bob ah a fine leg actually
let's wash it and make sure it's clean
it's got to make sure it's clean lake oh
that's a clean leg
he's got he's always oh sorry
[Music]
he always had good lengths i always
admired his legs
oh [ __ ] his blood levels [ __ ] i forgot
uh
[ __ ] all right what do i do then i got
to get a new one i got to get a new leg
does anyone have a leg does anyone have
a leg
uh let's see all right so he's almost
dead that's normal
five second rule five second rule five
second rule i'm coming with you his
right leg off and put it in the chute
oh the shoot all right got it no problem
we're cryogenically is this the shoe
is this the shoe
i'm starting to worry about you no no
it's good it's good it's good
he's got a new leg bob you're free
rip his right leg off and put it in the
chute all right all right
what are you doing that is not a right
leg what
what that's his left
i thought i'm so sorry bob can i tear
off his head then
[Music]
put it back oh okay we're fine four five
oh my god
great i did it yellow syringe to stop
bob's bleeding
yellow syringe oh god
i press this how do i stop bob's
bleeding with a yellow syringe
yeah but oh there it is okay
grab it
quick stop the bleeding with a yellow
syringe
i did it boss i stopped the bleeding
boss
perfect now grab the fresh leg and just
pop it on
done you got a new you got a new leg
he's a robot boss
here here cheers
he's fine he's fine i i know bob like i
know my right leg
all right oh that's a nice
that's a fresh leg
i could put the leg back
it's mine it's mine you can't stop us
you can't stop us it's my leg
oh god damn it all right let's put it
back lovely work remember
fine when you rip off an appendage bob
will bleed out very quickly
let's continue all right all right
diagnostics how we doing kiwi thank you
very much
again for the video uh
what's next i did it i did the job boss
ah we get to go through sweet looks like
bob's low on blood
give him a top up with a red syringe
first
oh messy business try not to kill him
this time
dear me poor bob try again
try not to kill him this time
it's okay top bob up with the red
syringe
all right grab it
he's looking better already rather than
just ripping off a limb
use a little more finesse this time why
don't you grab a saw
for good sawing grab this now straight
on
give it another shot to realign your
grip drop it and try again
align the saw with the cutting line
place it down gently and sew
back and forth until the limb drops off
[Music]
remember if you use the saw bob will
bleed out much more slowly
we will make him stronger
we'll make him stronger improved
improved bob will be better than ever
yes
yes that's my chat
yes my child
my child my child my child
yes saw his right arm off and popping oh
my god
all right fine [ __ ]
[Music]
just trying to i'm a professional god
damn it i don't need instructions from
a fool a scoundrel
yeah all right give me a fresh vod
ah fresh bye
where's the song
slap his right arm off and pop a fresh
one on where's the saw
where's the sock it's in here oh yes
yes all right
yes yes
which arm this one right
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
one click one clean cut do i
[Music]
oh i got it i got it i got it i got it
i got it i got it i got it
i got it i got it no
i got i got it i got it i got it
oh messy business sorry try not to kill
him this time
i'm trying to
[Music]
okay fresh bob
all right here we go
why won't you how is this less messy
than me just
dripping it up
[Music]
saw his right arm off and pop a fresh
one on yes i did it i did it i did it i
did it
a fresh one
that's how they do it the pros
swedish uh style surgery a lot of people
really are something i know now remember
setting the penis
no problem
no bob ah we continue all right cool
and finally an organ transplant remember
to use a diagnostic scanner
yeah transplant the sick organs must
come out
the rest of the organs are optional
crack the ribs with something heavy to
get at his lungs
grab a scalpel and stick it into a lung
to remove it
you can just rip organs out but bob will
bleed out much more
quickly god forgive me for what i must
do
[Music]
did i do it oh [ __ ] i'm good at this
crack the ribs remove the old lungs and
pop in some new ones
why would i pop in new ribs dude
i need i need something bigger to crack
them with
i'll crack them all right here we go
this is heavier
crack the ribs remove the old ones and
pop in some new ones
all right here we go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] we got his leg i don't even know
how that's possible
i'm a professional i know what i'm doing
crack the ribs
remove the old lungs
let's just make sure his legs
[Music]
he's gonna bleed dude
crack the ribs remove the old lungs
you're stressing me out woman
i think i know what i'm doing
there
[Music]
there no prize for second place
driver first all right i guess we'll
have to use uh
more traditional methods fine
oh sorry about that bob [ __ ]
i'm actually trying i'm not even
[ __ ]
okay this works
what is that is kidney liver
i don't know where ken is he's supposed
to be here but i think is that his brain
what the [ __ ]
i think the co-op aspect that starts
when you're
i'm just doing the tutorial right
all right we gotta stop deleting oh ken
wrote me on this card hold up ken
if you're listening i just gotta save
this name
he's gonna live he's gonna live kids
don't worry about
we gotta stop the bleeding as well
[Music]
there you go there you go he's safe
he's safe stop crying kids all right so
we got a
the lungs right
what is this
i my arm is not that long like okay here
we go
his line okay cool
all right now we get a fresh pair of
lunch
are you kidding me all right here we go
you're going to breathe fine all those
years of smoking
will cancel themselves out blink
it's like lego pieces they just fit
together
beautifully done remember yeah
he's already done the tutorial damn
kenneth surgery to the world
anyone no matter their background can
become a celebration i must be honest
all it takes is a can do attitude
high five guys that felt good high five
here
hit it hit it hit it smack it
yeah i do the whip i do the knitting
all right now i think we're ready for
ken
[Music]
welcome to the lobby before we move on
you should use the mirror to make sure
you're looking presentable oh yeah yeah
okay so you customize yourself now
i mean i do look damn good what do you
guys think
[Music]
uh but i do want to look more like a
surgeon right yeah
now i'm not a crazy surgeon yeah
all right so you unlock these
all right this looks more like me even
though it looks nothing like me at the
same time
you look splendid head out to the main
hall when you're ready
i actually think i look more like penny
to be honest
uh yeah i'm penny
all right so now we can interact with
ken i think see those big glass vac
tubes on the other side of the room
we can use those to get anywhere in the
entire facility
uh okay let me change so i can connect
with ken
all right calling can cut
it well well where where damn you're
fast at the tutorial man
i thought i was fast man
look you said i messed around for a long
time i know what you did
you had to talk to all the parts i speed
run that [ __ ] dude
so fast all right so
how do we connect i think we i think we
got in the escape menu it's got a
friends list but i don't think we're
friends
oh no oh we definitely epic friends yeah
i don't have any friends on epic i don't
think
let me have my screen i don't even know
how to open fa
okay actually i think i'm friends with
ninja on epics whatever
oh well maybe i'll invite him instead
yeah yeah he's pretty good at kids games
yes uh just kidding
he was okay in halo also hey
remember uh
yeah ninja online chat hey ninja
marshmallow perfect
sad face do you think he'll reply
yes all right let's write a message to
ninja
the chat everyone gets one word in so
write one word and i'll post it in the
order
all right go ahead start with hello
hello beautiful ninja ligma
cat sim
hello pickle face smurf ligma barrel
glue gang miss broccoli joe mama good
evening
ligma i can't believe the ligma shit's
still
going on [ __ ] half of people can't i
can't let the old memes go
red bull loser nice sweetie hello
pixellings
all right what a beautiful message
i i know how to
oh okay all right i think i'm
registering my emails so i'll write you
my email and then see if you can add
that
okay okay yeah i got my screen and
everything let me just uh see
hey the classic
that's the ad friend i also have a
request to jack but he never added me
that's kind of courage
how do i actually i'll put it in all
right while you do that i'm going to get
a gift
gpu which i figured i freaking had you
add
friend
gonna add friend button doesn't do
anything other good
there we go i seen it i seen it
oh oh chat's all mine again man this
takes me back
back in the day when we all we're
getting started on youtube still playing
the surgeon simulator oh
don't say anything bad i love it
it was a great game back then yeah
cool all right did you add me yet oh
yeah it did
did you ever get uh like the the i got
you that surgeon sent me
the surgeon simulator lunch box back in
the day from the first game they had
like the
gummy heart in it i think i did but i
had such a faint memory of it that i'm
not even sure if i did
yeah yeah get that thing forever until
it went real bad
friends a player name hang on
yeah i added you yeah i added you too
i'm all on him
is it going through the epic game or is
it it must
it's gotta be right it says you're
online
okay all right everyone write a message
maybe you're hidden
uh you may be hidden so you may have had
me then or invite me
oh [ __ ] no i'm online since i'm online
and i have you added you're literally on
my friendly
ad okay well like the the in-game ad
friends list that's what i'm talking
about
let's make a team free stop crying uh
what
friends edit yeah in in-game
like the party menu and stuff can you
see me walk up to the terminal and
interact uh hold up
i see i see a pot i see a jelly
if you hit escape it'll be on the right
side of the room
use it to send you know your dad because
you have actual patience with morons i
appreciate that
uh now wait
oh uh go go to the go to the station and
interact with it hit the play button
first
walk up to the terminal and enter okay i
got your stream pulled up so i can walk
you through it
just hit the continue story button okay
now select the first exercise in that
list
and click heart broken and click play
and then it'll tell you that you can
party
open it should be private then yes
hit play or whatever and then uh she'll
say that you can add your friends or
whatever i highly recommend bringing
some friends along
after all the more the merrier is one of
our mantras here at bossa labs
you can access your friends one friend's
online jacksepticeye
what the [ __ ] what do i need to reset my
gaming on
what's going on here uh
add friend toast ken
bum bum
maybe uh let me just reset the game real
quick and see if that
gets anything should i do the same
i don't know you know how it is now
these things are
all right game is uh game's not
completely launched yet so
maybe it's been having an issue i blame
epic games
where is my epic games at now and they
close
unless we gotta play through more but i
don't think we do no it said
clearly that you could invite more
[Music]
v-bucks communication so it's gotta work
yeah yeah
this is another doctor disrespect moment
what happened you guys can connect we
spend like 30 minutes just trying to add
each other
we are friends not in game
yeah uh joiner just correct okay i'm
starting the game now it's loading okay
go ahead
you do your thing man oh i will
um okay
this is my control panel daily
challenges oh [ __ ]
all right oh yeah you're awesome you're
like
yeah we did it
how good are your surgery though because
i don't know if i want to play with you
if you're not good
i'm like the the surgery simulator
you know i just simulate it man easy
well you did play the tutorial pretty
quickly and i'm gonna lie yeah and then
i
mastered the old game no rage ever
uh all right invited you are you in uh
i do not oh oh there goes you invite me
to join the party
i x clicking the accept button
nothing's happening
whoa that was a [ __ ] nice flip
all right i'm trying to accept it i mean
but you i guess if that works
you joined the party i guess it's just
[Laughter]
me
oh my god i got all the apples
what the [ __ ] we need to come back here
jesus christ
oh oh thank you for some apples i
brought i brought a gift oh my apologies
there you go drop the apples on the
floor how could you there yeah give me
those
oh yes maybe on a date keep it apple's
it keeps the doctor away
you're literally disintegrating you're
being that us right now
put me on him on fire i'm lit fam
hey does this look weird on your face
got your nose oh my nose give it back
give it back i'm a plastic surgeon
rhinoplasty ah oh no no
oh [ __ ] you found me
[Laughter]
you'll never find me okay hide and seek
one
all right two okay three yeah four
uh five yeah six yeah
seven eight nine ten ready or not here i
come where'd you go
where are you hello you'll never find me
oh my god this is just like playing hide
and seek with my kids at the house it's
like where
where could he be
[Music]
oh definitely not a trash can falling
down over there where is he over here
behind the pudding no
no i'm not a child ken i don't need your
patronizing coat i found you
give me that oh give me come on come on
that's not cool
that's not my bucket that's not cool my
bucket that's it
what the [ __ ]
i can't witness my powers oh
i have bucket manipulation powers like
magneto
i'm controlling it too force field
all right should we play the game y'all
crouch down
all right we need to uh yeah play the
game
i'm heartbroken maybe since you invited
me you should start it
okay continue the story
heartbroken our party is private
you bet your ass it is boy i mean
there's like the matter if it's open or
private really because
you bet your rams it is boy can't go
take him
sorry i liked it yeah it was nice
hold up
why are you burning
[Laughter]
i'm just oh
oh my oh
thank you don't touch me oh we gotta go
in here
i got you cool let's go
rolling out going to space
oh [ __ ] here we go oh yeah you can be
burning too you have the same outfit i
think
yeah but i'm an actual doctor oh
i'm not i'm more of a i'm more of a mad
scientist myself no i'm an actual doctor
i got a phd in doctor things
whatever you say you're my am i your
nurse are you my nurse
oh oh because i'm a woman i'm a nurse is
that what you're saying no
well me i could be the nurse also i'll
be your nurse
doctor all right poor bob's house on its
way out
luckily our bioreplicator unit the broom
heartbroken produced a replacement the
brew is our greatest achievement he's
dying ken
oh my god hurry up oh my god
where is he first we got to sanitize we
got yeah
we got it we got a beer we got to
sanitize yeah we got sanitized very
important to sanitize before anything
else just drink this you got to sanitize
okay
all right my turn all right all right
get the
[ __ ] out of here we're doing surgery
[Laughter]
oh of course we're cause we're actual
doctors
i lost i got my height i found whoever
fox get away move
i'm looking for my id card
just misplaced it back here behind these
boxes here we go
doctor all right i got my id card
boom all right we're good to go
[Applause]
just grab it don't don't push don't push
me don't
grab it doctor grab
all right here we go
all right oh plenty of towels in case
the patient gets cold very very nice
nice
oh nice oh these are cashmere
someone's messed with the fridge door
huh
hey what what someone's missing the
fridge door what fridge door
oh yeah oh what is this
uh it's to get them out i think okay
i played the tutorial and i paid
attention so
yeah oh we only have so many too okay we
got a limited amount all right
maybe we should not waste them all right
you ready doctor oh you need the
patience you need the key curry
bob awaits you check the diagnostic
scanner to see what that's fine
what the diagnostics say i don't where's
the hair catch
oh oh it's fine
he's fine he's fine
all right wait wait part replace success
can you change the limbs see if you put
that on i don't know this is easy
oh yeah an arm okay we can try this is
science bob would have wanted this
yes
attach that that leg doctor i am i know
what i'm doing he needs more blood
[Music]
no this is your fault you're
unprofessional
how could you unbelievable
oh that ass that's my leg
how dare you all right we're off to a
great start doctor
so far so good bob would have wanted it
that way
yes yes luckily our bioreplicator unit
the brew
has produced a replacement the brew is
our greatest achievement oh yeah you got
the key card right perfectly
yes right here on there i get mine as
well all right
there we go
it worked nice
[Laughter]
let me get the blood thing so he don't
die this time
right right right we gotta get we get
this heart we gotta where the tools at
all right something to break the rib
cage with
uh we can use the needle to break the
cool yeah
my work apparently
my point of view what
what where are you in the window
just turn around
[Laughter]
i'm doing surgery here i'm a doctor i'm
a serious doctor
i'm sorry doctor i shouldn't question
your methods this isn't a playground you
know
all right we need to get this rib case
open okay
okay don't worry bring the pieces all
right
ribcage open oh nice let me get this
other one
oh [ __ ] he's losing blood he's losing
blood [ __ ] his arms fell off
what happened it's on this side oh
both his arms uh bob
he's going to be okay there's another
armament oh [ __ ]
how could you you're the unprofessional
one here
oh my god unbelievable
i am trying to do serious surgery here
your methods are they're unprecedented
yours
may be unorthodox but they do do the job
i may have misjudged your doctor
i concur doctor yes yes greatest
achievement and works almost perfectly
all right seriously no more jokes ken
okay no more jokes no more jokes sick of
your jokes
your little jokester now your turn
thank you all right bob
awaits you the table actually worked as
a good
way to ruin the ribcage oh yeah yeah
perfect perfect go ahead and
you just gotta hit it right yeah yeah i
think his leg
fell off yeah yeah don't worry i'll just
reattach that yeah just
get that leg back on there is it off um
yeah oh are you serious how could you
doctor
how could you
all right i know i said serious but i uh
okay all right you take the lead this
time all right
you take the lead you show them how it's
done
we'll do it in the south oh yes yeah
perfect
i want to see how it's done in the south
oh yeah i'll show you how to turn this
out don't you worry about that
the brew has produced a replacement the
brew is our greatest achievement and
works
almost perfectly uh
something's wrong doctor oh never mind
my body was just
disconnected from my head for a moment
i'm fine
all right i'll bring the towels
make sure he doesn't believe that all
right maybe i'll get the needles then
make sure it doesn't bleed okay i just
need uh
i see the paint bucket perfect
man there we go bob
yes bob awaits you check the diagnostic
scanner to see what's ailing him
oh we should check the diagnostic
scanner you know we already checked that
old
knife down the south here looks like uh
he's he's
got an unhealthy heart yeah okay we got
all right
too much barbecue let's pump him i think
uh
he's gonna need some oxygen jump up on
here on the uh on the table here and
just put your butt over his face and
you know give a mouth to to anus
perfect like yes yes now just
just give him a little a little a little
bit of a little
yes nice
he likes it oh bob all right now we
break the rib cage
you know a couple of tip taps here damn
you're good at that with a paint can
yes doctor i'm a southern doctor wow so
the
doctor all right the hearts are in the
way doctor what do we do
the law yes this this the the breathing
the vape mechanisms are in the way
perfect
what do we do all right i just throw
them on the ground over there yeah i
mean just grab this heart here and oh
yeah reach in there just grab that heart
and rip it out mortal kombat style
should i say something cool before i do
it finish here
how's he feeling oh he's bleeding out
real fast i got i got
i got a doctor did you get the new heart
uh where okay new heart new heart why is
he
leaving doctor where's the new heart at
i don't know over here maybe we should
have
your heart someone's messed with the
fridge door
i can only keep him alive it's longer
where'd the heart go i gotta put it in
the box over here to get a new one
yeah this is definitely a smoking heart
smoker's heart smoker heart
where's the heart at maybe it's in this
other room over here open
find the heart doctor i keep
you gotta keep going oh my god
let me in
where's the heart at oh maybe it's in
here
maybe some stairs jesus this place is
huge
oh my old office an office
is the blood in there you got more bl
what
what oh they got a little bit of portal
story going on here
someone someone the vince warning me
you can trust people in vents in
hospitals right never too soon to plan
ahead
where is the heart set i figured it'd be
like nearby somewhere
i'm stopping the bleeding where are they
i put g fuel in his system he should be
able to live forever he doesn't need a
heart now
he's immortal okay bob
is sick he needs a new heart all right
well let's i can help you find a heart
man
yeah okay that's great find a heart
i don't have one do you no
wait is there like a little container
like there used to be with a heart in it
somewhere i found it i found it
where it was upstairs
the whole time i'll show you oh perfect
good job doctor no problem
so all right so just get him
careful doctor careful okay okay okay
i know you're watching so i want to do
good
upper pressure press i'm holding it i'll
put pressure
put pressure it's gonna push it in there
pressure
get up just shove it in pressure shoot
oh
[Music]
oh no oh i think he's bleeding out oh
he's fine it's fine
oh god he did it doctor i actually need
to give him blood
okay
good job doctor i hear the stabbing is
going well
he's alive he's moving he's trying to
tell us something
the heart has got to be in here but it's
not like letting me in
look this is here look take it
that's there how many both of the key
cards
yeah but that's yeah you got to put it
in there
yeah what the [ __ ] oh it's number three
we need number one
oh okay what's up in the office then uh
[ __ ] we're smart we're like doctors dude
we're like do you like doctors or
something man i feel like i'm so
big brain right now uh let's see here
nice nice someone had to do it
i'm glad it was you doctor i trust you
with bob's life now we can go and have
some drugs
i mean we can oh we're not done yet [ __ ]
murder simulator hey
we're saving bob's life oh good job
doctor
you know arms and legs don't belong in
there
but he's here for a heart transplant
doctor you better little bonus has never
heard anything oh that's true
actually you know i've got very good
health insurance a little bonus
a little bonus for the health insurance
all right you tear off the arm and i'll
put in the new one
wait for [ __ ] sake
sorry sad please please stop
oh i kid you i kid you doctor
please this is not part of the protocol
please no
no
[Laughter]
all more we did it a plus oh well nice
it should have been a plus we didn't
keep him from losing all the blood
though
you had one job doctor that was easy
easy yeah easiest game i played in my
life
ah so easy easy i'm ready to be a real
doctor now
oh yeah julian says this one should be
tip top
let's just see about that oh tip top
that's my
motto in life again what's in the trash
can here
yo they got [ __ ] tubes here dude whoa
bruh
tubes how are you on fire all the time
i'm lit fam damn fan you sure are
hey all right well if you're lit then
dab for me
damn damn damn
hey look here's how you died
yeah damn high five
that's high high five
one two three high five
nice yeah nice nice
one two three cross grab yeah
nice nice nice nice
it's about my nice bro it smells like
smelling it's like old legs
legs you like legs yeah i like legs mine
smell like
like an old heart but vape
juice is dipped in it oh yeah yeah my
banana
melon vape that's right banana melon
that's a great
[Laughter]
let's go with that there's no time for
games doctor all right
there's a there's a bot we got to build
all right we gotta get this
sanitized yeah i got the sponge
we'll clean each other for effectiveness
yes
i respect you so much doctor i respect
you so much more
for your cleanliness all right we
couldn't do without you
oh bobby bring in the patient don't
worry about god
don't worry bob you're going to be okay
you're going to be
it looks like he's bleeding already i
got his brain
perfect we can now make more of lame
well that's a big brain that is a
big ass brainbot oh he's definitely
bleeding out very quickly is he bleeding
because of the brain damage
[ __ ] all right no never it couldn't be
that
he's got brain damage all right i'm
sorry i'm sorry sorry
all right don't i just let me get this
the blood stopper here yeah let me just
stop this blood there you go you're
gonna live bob
brains are overrated yeah you don't need
brains
there you go just
bleeding ketchup and mustard that's all
we need
[Laughter]
perfect all right what are we trying to
do to bob here looks like his arms are
unhealthy and need replacing
okay yeah let me just go through this
event here
that's a bit unorthodox it won't let me
through
what does that do oh basketballs
you want a little bit of one-on-one
[ __ ] scare me
right there it is right there this blue
stuff where's the ball oh [ __ ] it's big
the ball remember here
i got the mustard [ __ ] i got the mustard
okay sweet pumping fulwin mustard now
doctor
drink this bob he's daddy of course he
can't do it you got to shove it in
[ __ ] perfect
he's fine i think he's better already
his mustard bar it still says zero
on the yellow mustard oh that's a low
mustard bar we're gonna have to
yes do something about that oh the arms
are depleted here oh yeah oh but the
legs are ready oh we got productive legs
there we go nice all right so i place it
in
while you tear it off
here get the leg i'll tear off the leg
and you replace with the new one all
right but we could need to replace his
arms
put the knife all right all right new
leg
attached and improved oh it worked yes
perfect yes yes yes new leg new leg new
leg
a left now they're both they can be left
and right it doesn't matter right
yeah he could be um yeah
buddy you ready doctor i don't think i'm
here all right i'm not very good at
attaching them
oh he's beautiful wow you look good
nice wait there's one there's one
missing
one more leg trust me all right all
right
you got the leg yeah leg right leg
one two three leg leg
he's complete yes our masterpiece
oh did we what do we
why did did we not beat the level i
don't understand
i don't understand what happened i put
this head on ice though you know just
keep it i think that's it
we're done we're done right
all right what does it want what are you
doing doors are locked
ah strange it's so much like we didn't
finish the mission arrow button here
what is this
here catch
past the rock
come on you can do it come on you can
just throw it up here it's a meatball
here
look at that meatball
pat pass me the meatball
nice oh damn that's smart
does this work yeah yeah of course the
amiibo won't fit in the hole
uh maybe if you jump on my shoulders
okay okay
i don't think that works doctor it
didn't work
i think we could just not work i think
we may have done the surgery wrong
impossible oh of course we never changed
his legs
oh yeah with the the monitor says
yes the legs has got to be the legs ah
the legs of course
pause of course i can't
reach the i can't reach the leg
do you have something to get the leg out
with
um yeah yeah i got some some useless
thing right here on the ground
all right all right i can just yeah i
got the lighting moving it yeah
just come here okay
okay it keeps rolling under me come here
give it to me i
got one of those too i don't know what i
don't know where this is but
i got one too come on give me it no no
here here
the problem is this one you see it's
kind of like stuck
where are you i'm i was next to you
oh doctor are you oh i just couldn't see
you for some reason doctor
i can't the leg is stuck i can't reach
it there you go you did it
all right cool all right so now perfect
get the leg and we replace his legs
yes like like okay which leg
like leg leg leg like
legs transformation
perfect one more one more one more one
more leg one more leg leg leg leg leg
yes yes yes you ready you got yeah
you're not ready come on
i'm ready i'm ready i was born ready
he's gonna bleed out if you [ __ ] up all
right like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna leg
oh god get it on what did i say what it
what did i say put it back put it back
put it back put it back okay okay okay
put it back okay okay here i'll
put the leg
yeah that's it that's it all right we'll
switch sides switch side
yay leg leg leg
leg
[Music]
we win did we win
we haven't won we haven't run there
seems to be some red
buttons or marks on here pointing at his
new leg arms and head
because it means we did it wrong no
that's perfect yeah spider-man
oh oh sorry oh
who is this oh
oh seems to be bleeding out very quickly
oh
oh uh i don't think he's gonna make it
nurse or doctor no it wasn't on
no
are you serious
what a shame what a shame lost another
one oh well
bring in the next patient next spot
please
this you think you get some [ __ ]
thanks
you think you guys are so ungrateful
all right speed run speed run speed how
do you get in this other room that's why
i figured out yet
oh we were changing the arms oh
yeah no yeah
all right you get some new arms then
[ __ ]
i didn't think he was so picky with what
he wanted i'm sorry i really don't know
why these doors are locked
i got to put something in here and drop
it i think
i'll pump him up with some uh extra
g-fuel pewdiepie flavor
nice nice if you give him enough he
might become immortal
and a god but he'll have to be careful
with the dosage
[Music]
foreign
dang it
why is it
there it is
oh i did it holy [ __ ] man
holy [ __ ] you are so smart i had never
doctor the
doctor from the south thank you thank
you dr from the sweden
from the smoothie don't get an arm out
of here oh we gotta
put the old arms in before it gives us a
new arm ah
okay okay okay i'll stop the bleeding
you uh you get the uh uh arm
that perfect the top legs or whatever
they are did you oh you
you [ __ ] did it without it all right
what this is our nurses
we never get the the thanks for what we
do
it's not giving me an arm do i have to
have both of them
uh maybe you're supposed to get them
from the other room
the legs
why is this working maybe we need to
like uh
donate like a ball or something
like something valuable
maybe uh maybe like essential oils
nah wait what
wait what oh what oh we were supposed to
saw
the legs off you think that's it
oh wait what's in here then no i mean i
just gonna make a round
we got the arms left and right oh
they're backwards of course doctor
oh of course of course
not just any old arm yes of course
what arm do i have i don't know just
stick it on there and see what happens
uh
i think this is right
i think this is as good as it's gonna
get that's as good as it gets right
there
get on
connect you son of a gun uh well done
well done bye bob bye
it's like we just discovered that we
have arms
well done doctor i'm proud
[Music]
all right we got a talent i'll say that
can't be beaten when it comes to
doctrine
i'm very impressed at how you've taken
to the unique nature of office all right
what is this
okay if we do it in under eight minutes
we get extra points so
oh my god oh my god oh my god
what is with this office it's all ruined
and crazy
oh oh a large intestine are those left
arms are there
sofas i like what brother oh yeah
well i kind of like the blue sofa yeah
you know for our living room
or is it mattress it's the sleeping bags
yes oh yes
swag bag sleeping bags yeah
uh where's bob oh here
who is that where where is the patient
i'm too thick push me
what oh
push me i'm coming don't worry
get that fat ass in there can you fit
through there
no no no i can't that what's the point
my
brain is too big i don't know maybe you
can just like pass things to one another
through there
oh maybe one of us can go at a time
the door's locked oh my god
like it's not tough enough doing surgery
we gotta figure out how to [ __ ] get
in
you'll need an arm to get through here
we need an arm
the guys oh my god the doctor gotcha
needs an arm
no problem oh my god a zombie arm right
bra
i just said an arm all right an arm oh i
want
i got one oh perfect
yeah that one looks nice and fresh it it
smells like
vape juice again oh my god
so straight
oh more more ketchup and mustard oh hot
dog
oh hot dog a wiener
you want a taste oh a scented candle
candle candle can't candle
it's a vape flavored hot dog you want
taste oh hear me
[Music]
oh scalpel all right let's get
all right what does he want uh his
intestines and a new
brain arm and a leg
god oh [ __ ] we're trapped one of us was
only supposed to
go in oh no
[Music]
oh no hardcore parkour
a button right here there's a button on
the wall it's open yay
oh or you can do that yeah yeah yeah all
right i'll go
all right pass me a leg or something
okay i'll go get a leg and pass it
oh it's gonna be a left leg no i don't
think i actually i actually don't think
it matters
oh i need to bring another leg in here
this area is not set up as intended
i'm afraid i need his own leg doctor
he'll be fine he'll be fine doctor i
can't get the leg out unless i have
another leg
really oh that's why we need to pass him
because we need him fast
yes yes all right his uh his right leg
come on gotta give him some must all
right all right
all right bro his right leg but wait
wait wait it's his left leg
no this is is his right leg okay here's
his right leg
i got a new leg it's coming here you go
new leg new leg hold up i gotta stop
bleeding i got the new leg right here
new leg no leg new leg no leg
leg their legs their legs
[ __ ] i catch it you can do it
it's stressing me out man oh you butter
fingers doctor
it's on i connected
i was the guy i'm almost there
boom your leg your leg leg nice
all right now we need his his left arm
are you right
let me check his values all right he's
fine left arm
the other arm the other left arm
yeah you're his left your right who's
left
that one oh
speed run speed
where's it we still gotta open up his
guts too new arm
come here oh chair get away
amnesia references mr chair please mr
chair
chair mode activate
there we go stop the bleeding doctor
thank you
man you're so good at this i'm very good
at passing things it was my major in
college
oh god you really are at that huh
all right let's grab the scalpel here
and uh we'll just get right to work
oh that that says i should cut his leg
now we'll just use the soap instead i'll
pump it
in the cemetery there you go
why don't more people do that
are you okay there doctor yeah it's not
working
unbelievable
i don't think you need to crack it open
because we're it's a brain transplant
hold up first of all
i got it you did it oh we gotta swap it
out
where is it doctor where is that just
keep going where is it
yeah keep going where is it yeah right
right in here
give me a new one [ __ ] i fell on the
floor is that okay
yeah that's fine that's fine just spit
on it and wipe it off
perfect sanitary it's clean it's clean
you pass it through the hole you don't
have to go
back that's fine i did it
[Applause]
together we're unstoppable we can't be
stopped a team
let's continue fbi is watching what the
[ __ ]
oh fbi just know your location oh god oh
god
oh we're not doing anything
we're not doing anything oh man oh dude
we got the a plus
yeah that's always done yeah read your
[ __ ]
and they said it couldn't be done
fbi opened up
nina has some trials of her own going on
somewhere in labs
she's making real progress where on
earth is the diagnostic scanner
julian
excuse me doctor oh
i thought you were doctor oh god i
thought you were
i'm so sorry i thought you were uh i was
okay doctor please continue
okay
very good doctor let me just read these
doc
oh my walking chair
i helped you to your walking chair
was that what it's called a walking
chair uh it's just a walker
how does it work you uh you hold it with
your arms and you walk and like move it
forward it keeps
keeps you balanced for old people like
this you you don't have old people in
sweden
no they all get killed at the age of 40.
for the best through the meatball ritual
that's how meatballs are made
oh yes what's wrong with this bob i
can't tell
uh oh [ __ ] i guess we just have to do uh
um oh what's wrong with this bob
what is this i got a treadmill
oh nice oh it's for hearts
maybe
okay all right got it
heal the patient okay we gotta so we're
gonna have to find the uh
somewhere in this level probably is
hidden the thing we need to look at to
figure out what's wrong with him
yeah right yeah yeah yeah yeah uh you're
here
is it this yo yo
yo there's a little vent to go through
right here yeah all right
it's not that
oh this needs a little okay we need to
find a
fuse tonight oh yeah it says here on the
chalkboard oh i knew that
uh yeah no problem no prob
have you seen a few somewhere have you
seen the fuse
no well this one's refusing all right i
feel stupid for asking
no if he was there either these are two
views
two fours what the hell
that too many foods man
can you break these locks probably not
where the [ __ ] are the fuses
trash can no oh maybe in here doctor
oh it locked yeah we need a fuse for
that door too oh maybe in here
we need to make a transfusion
[Laughter]
did you read the joke for your chat no
no
no shut up
shut your [ __ ] mouth man how dare you
maybe you've been reading the chat
there's all that
a shout the chat sorry the cheese
the chat sorry i can't say shot
apparently
there's a duck in there where's the fuse
well it's a few all right fires up here
oh those are not fuses already
where stop yours oh
i found a hidden place probably a small
brain
southerners can't find it
we need to give you and we need to give
you a brain
[Laughter]
good job good job real good job real
solid work there
here's how it's done a real man well man
needs to do it
jelly bro this is like outlast too
please pretend you're not seeing this
okay wait what is that oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you did it nice deers
oh you can wait
this door's open now julian has freshly
stocked the storeroom for you
ah the diagnostic machine scanner
battled you nicely i found the origin
origin oregon did you let me in here
uh yeah let me out yeah i didn't like
you
how i got the projector
yeah all right well put it through the
vent
where's the band
no pain for me to put it through i can't
excuse me go through
yes
my hand seems to be stuck in the door
[Music]
okay i'm going i made it yeah well done
doctor
well done well done i never doubted you
for seconds
now and go see what's wrong with bob
let's go check what's wrong with bobby
boo
get off get all this junk out of the way
who stacked all these tables up
move no put it
this is
give it to me give it to me doctor
all right okay let's put it just put it
on the thing here's right here just
right right here
i'll cut you you do it then
it'll shaky there buddy i can't stand up
all right my turn
[Laughter]
oh good i can read it i knocked it over
you taking two turns my turn
oh i'm sorry
[Laughter]
let's look how a pro does it
all right i'll just hold this his
stomach and his
right leg his left leg stomach and his
left leg and his heart
jesus it's cobblestone generator all
over again
all right okay driving now driving out
overnight
get out of the way so i can scoot over
scoot over
what i didn't do anything okay let's
place it down
there you go perfect yeah high five
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right so we got a yeah you didn't
finish it you didn't finish it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right
the old face grab right there
[ __ ] it's not complete without that
and then
that's it yeah we did it yeah
oh forgot forgot
i can't it's not complete without the
tourney though ending
building yeah the old nato and they all
back and forth yeah they all yeah yeah
yeah and then the one jumping on the box
[Applause]
ah that was close try to get training
all right one two three yeah
and they all and they all touch the
stranger touch the string yeah that
stranger danger here we go
and then finishing up finishing out yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's about
perfect and then the old walk sticker
room
[Applause]
and then the final
you can do it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
try to grab it midair we did it we did
it what a great handshake
yeah let's we did it high five yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the box the bugs
[Laughter]
oh he knocked the thing off what
happened to bob i don't know anymore
[Laughter]
it's a patient doctor and he's a patient
a patient patient there he's a patient
patient yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
there we go oh perfect i gotta find some
blood stoppage thingies
oh i got it i got plenty of this yeah
yeah oh [ __ ] sake you didn't grab them
before
what oh there's a conveyor belt i can
just like hand you oh bread
no come come out of there oh toast nice
look
look sentiment jokes
jokes
[Laughter]
hey i'm gonna i want to start a new show
chat what do you think i should call it
something cinnamon toast ah so original
oh
i thought of that wow that's so helpful
guys thank you so much
[Laughter]
hey isn't there another toast guy on
twitch
uh oh yeah disguise toast yeah yeah what
are we gonna do about him
i don't know people come by be like oh
you're just copying him and i was like
please jesus
um i'm the og toast all right well here
i
thought it was cool yeah well you got
that right
there we go get in there how could you
okay okay
uh oh there's like i have a tear on my
cheek from laughing still
[Music]
[Laughter]
blood stoppage i got the blood stopper
all right i got the bloodish
we we gotta stock up okay yeah let's put
them right here on the table
there you go
perfect thank you thank you no worries
one more
[Music]
i think we'll make the time limit on
this one oh yeah we've been pretty time
to figure oh yeah
the surgery hasn't actually started yet
why are you giving him blood already
oh you gotta pump in some extra that
doesn't hurt oh yeah
he doesn't need some blood you're right
you're right you got a problem with my
methods
all right no doctor i need to bring you
a stomach and a heart and a
what is that in the middle how's the
heart
oh stomach heart leg summer heart leg
i get the leg you get the heart i get
the stomach and the weight chair oh we
can use the conveyor belt
oh nice heart yeah
oh they because they're gonna be i think
you might need them to be kind of fresh
and what do we need their stomach wait
we're stuck we're stuck
what how maybe we're stuck
how this the fuse must have fallen out
no we made the fuse falling out no no
we're gonna die
i know it's all right we got plenty of
snake we got plenty of food for oh yeah
we can live for a while i can just do me
to eat them start starving
i'll feed you you open up
oh wait maybe the door doesn't open if
you use the conveyor belt oh
i mean i would like to eat that but
maybe first we should check this oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah we just grab a stomach
here then we're fine we're fine
okay not that none of those stomachs are
bad stomachs why are we stuck
we did everything perfect can i turn it
off
in the middle that work is it the toes
it's because we took the toes not the
toast
[ __ ] i knew we shouldn't have touched it
damn it
uh what do you say we restart i don't i
don't know if we actually messed up or
this is supposed to happen
now maybe i guess we gotta restart
unless i can like turn this off i put it
in the middle in it i guess the power
back but that one
shouldn't matter
you [ __ ] it up doctor you [ __ ] it up
no no oh
yes [ __ ] ceiling
forget the interruption at the end of
the last surgery the chairs was keeping
it open oh
that was a chair on the ground that i
moved oh come on
she's making real progress where on
earth is the diagnostic scanner
oh because we didn't yeah it was kept
open with the okay
what we didn't have the fuse in here we
still had it in for the other room and
it was open because of yeah okay what
yeah you talking [ __ ] boy yeah there was
a chair keeping the door open but we
didn't actually have the fuse in so the
door was locked the whole time but it
was kept up
until i moved the uh why
oh [ __ ] sake
i'm gonna give a lady or a hand here oh
never mind got it
oh you got it
i'm not independent but i'm strong
[Music]
i may be a woman but i'm not
independently
i may be independent but oh wait how the
[ __ ] is it open
a diagnostic i don't know how do we keep
getting around these locked doors
i think that the whatever's on the
ground opened it for us
all right well let's keep it that way i
don't know if i can get out though
oh mail date
but it should not be open right now
because it's green even you're right
definitely not be open i don't know
what's wrong with this guy's stomach
heart he's not even here yet what the
[ __ ] leg oh yeah i gotta push the button
okay command surgery
oh yes stomach heart and left leg let's
not both go in the same room at the same
time all right
okay i'll get the uh
all right so you passed me the things
through the conveyor belt while i
pumping phone with the g-fuel all right
uh what do you want first you want the
left leg first oh wait the legs are in
the other room aren't they
no way there this is the left leg
yeah i'll give you the left leg you send
me a toast god damn it
what is this i'm a professional i can't
work in any of these
conditions oh never mind the legs stuck
i need a leg
step it's stuck on the conveyor belt uh
don't worry i can fix this
yeah grab this let's see here yeah
god dang it bob i can't use a leg as a
tote you change the
way of the yeah cause the legs
all right i can send you back to the
toes then
leg leg leg
leg
get in that boy where are you
where's the leg where's the leg where's
the leg it's on the floor it's on the
floor
oh [ __ ] i didn't realize he's
unprofessional what are you talking
about
my methods maybe i don't know
insane but becomes a heart he's a lie
wait wait we're not ready for the art
dude here's your stomach
what are you talking about all right
you you do it and i'll cure him
i don't think that's hard enough why
does this work
i don't know it's crazy my coffee mug
here this will work for sure
yeah coffee mug will do
damn it come on we're running out of
time
keep him alive doctor uh yeah he's fine
yeah bones all right oh my amnesia got
worked yay
it carries okay the skull works oh [ __ ]
bone breaks bones bone on bone action
all right
let me just grab this long oh this lung
perfect perfect yes yes yes i keep keep
pressure there all the other
oh we grab that let me grab that
come on no bleeding so far just grab it
just just tear everything out just tear
everything out
yeah he doesn't need to eat this you're
right yeah get that out
get your hand away from me bob grabbing
me pull this brain out like you call it
uh stomach getting to this side all
right all right
let me get my come on man you got i
can't reach under the
i need a woman's touch uh i can't do it
i'm too busy
god dang it bob don't you oh the arm
fell off it's okay
i'll just uh dude uh
okay you gotta be uh
yeah is it bleeding out
uh yes
[Laughter]
absolutely uh where's the heart and
stomach oh there's the stomach on the
ground right there oh yeah we got the
stomach
nice nice nice put it in put it in but
easy easy clap nope
don't know if he's gonna die or not
knock the thing off
put it hard in there where's that egg
oh
we did it though we did it we [ __ ]
nailed it dude yeah
yeah yeah we did it
all right let's do one more all right
have you been playing long enough
i think one more will do the tray yeah
oh got a bag head
let's speed run it yeah the game is easy
that used to be for sure but they've had
like all the extra level stuff which is
kind of cool
i sent julian into tidy up in here so
this one
julian [ __ ] is julian
building this place has been shannon
marbles oh see
these are particularly difficult
but don't worry everything is fine well
certainly we'll be fine
right julian right
right all right he just needs a new arm
that's easy is that it
yeah for real for real
uh all right got one here
oh it's a right arm yeah
that's a left arm but okay a little
basic i know but it seems like the
nonsense is over
carry on oh it continues
get some syringes yeah i'll bring some
extra
this is a horror game
amnesia bro barrels they're behind this
oh not the barrels not their barrels
can't trust them can it's okay chair
mode activate
give me your pig voice piggy yeah yeah
wait you gotta grab something sensual
like a bowling ball oh yeah
yeah it's so sexy
i roll it to you bro oh bruh oh nice bro
roll it back to me bro oh bro
i roll it back to you bro rolly rolly
oh
nice bro nice pass pass it back to me
bro
don't cross the ball bro
yeah jump scares
everywhere oh what is this oh yeah for
electricity i got it
did that do anything
no
no didn't work push it again
you're not pushing it right i was a
refusal right
[Laughter]
where's the fuse go uh
uh maybe we need to move stop oh maybe
we gotta like
platform up to where the boxes are oh my
god
oh that's easy
tomorrow i'm so scared right now bro oh
you're not good at platforming are you
excuse me i'm a muric in the quest all i
know is platforms
i'm just trying to grab the box and i
jump it's not working
she's gotta be standing up there to get
it
grab
so can we go in here oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
jump down hang on i'm getting a
flashlight it's okay
oh [ __ ] i jumped oh jesus holy [ __ ]
where am i happening i'm coming
i'm coming i need you i'm not coming
because this freaking brooms handle
keeps hitting me in the face
i need you i'm coming
dude what's wrong with my character
okay it's my arm messing me up
where'd you go dude where did you go
i went through the hole there you are
oh you got a flashlight yeah yeah
yes yes indeed i can't turn the
flashlight around
where did we go oh oh oh i got to open
the doors here i think
can we grab them i tried to do it oh
okay okay okay you just i wasn't strong
enough
wait wait wait there's something here oh
big brain ah yes
oh the fuse is there yeah we're good
just flip the switch
does this change anything oh yeah the
doors are opening there's a fuse on the
ground
or on the thing behind you too closed
them
now they're open should i grab the fuse
just to be safe
uh i think so i think this next is gonna
need one yeah yeah
i'll put his feet on the ground
there's something you should know about
this place [ __ ] we're solving puzzle
before
no my fuse oh sorry we're solving
puzzles before they're
even appearing nice
we can continue now let's continue um
yes doctors
doing surgery the story is getting
intriguing barrels
i knew it can't trust
you can never do and they're in every
video game that says a lot about society
soft drink [ __ ] we need another fuse
yeah don't worry i just put the soft
drink in here and it'll all work just
fine
okay okay okay perfect
it didn't work it didn't work i think
there's a soft drink okay i pulled it
out there's a fuse on the ground don't
worry
that's not a all right sure
i'll get the fuse i'll get i'll get the
fuse wait this is not a fuse
i'll get the fuse what is this
it's not a fuse yeah i'm not amused
okay what is this i got it this is the
glow light
i got it it's one of those things you
your mom has it's not working okay
here we go for [ __ ] sake you
can pull it out pull it out
yeah tell me what's going on dude i'm
going in boy
see ya next time
we gotta crank this soldier boy
you just have to say that didn't you oh
i fell down
oh my god there's arms and legs and
stuff down here
where are you i did it too come on bro
hell yeah
doctor i'm so scared what the hell is
happening
there's some kind of a crazy story going
on i don't understand it
oh all the spooky spooky skates oh no
slender man slenderman ah
hang on i didn't get a good reaction let
me let me come in again
yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay all right
all right three no no hurry up oh yeah
yeah three two one all right ken i'm in
here
[Applause]
add a subtitle to that billions of views
baby yeah billions of views anything
with subtitles
it's [ __ ] hilarious everyone oh yeah
oh yeah
if it wasn't funny before the subtitles
will surely do the trick
[Laughter]
now it's funny it has subtitles
it's like every five nights at freddy's
gameplay ever
i can't even see where i'm going there's
a flashlight on the ground there little
bro
you grab it bro okay damn they're saying
you deserve an oscar
i do i know i deserve a billion million
views
but i'll never get them come no
yeah yeah if you can complete this pull
yourself together surgeon okay
okay this is a surgeon simulator god
dammit that's some sort of crying
simulator
you're right i feel like a real surgeon
right now
oh [ __ ]
all right here is this is not working
it's not working we need a fuse here
not another fuse are you kidding me yeah
we need a fuse
or i'll find the fuse all right i'll
find the fuse
i'll find i'll find a few stones don't
worry don't worry i'll find fuse
uh don't worry i got the fuse
i found a piece let me
[Laughter]
don't worry about it maybe the fuse is
inside you you
worry about the fuse i'll worry about
some blood thingy in here
and some more blood thingies in here and
a fuse
i found a fuse good job doctor around of
you doctor
now kill him i mean put it in
you don't have to ask me twice doctor uh
where does it go where did it go
right here but the flashlight here's how
to remember
yes we will carry him
what's wrong with him uh he needs a
large
his intestines large intestine
and a small dang it small and large
intestine
well i found some uh some blood thingies
in here let me bring them out
what are you what do we get intestines
that i
subscribe
i'll just have to use yours
[Music]
that's fine oh here we go here we go
here's here's some stuff
all right if you come in here i can
direct you
okay you can just grab whatever i need
where'd you go oh oh oh yes yes
oh i think i think there's another lever
we got to hit to like
oh there's a button there's not like
push them down if there's
another lever to those little squares in
the background don't push them out or
anything
this oh
hey idiot i found the brain intestine
the brain intestine i'll put it over
here by him
all right i'll get the other in is that
the only intestine
uh it's the blue one we need also that
rip it out all right
the couch intestine
okay i don't think we have any yeah the
couch intestine
oh you're bleeding uh-oh
oh i got it i got it i got it i got it
it's coming here coming right up
okay okay he's only got like two
thousand blood left
no don't make him dead two thousand five
hundred
yeah it's going down pretty slow though
okay well let's get the syringes
did you not find any yeah they were up
in the uh they couldn't get them out
though i couldn't
freaking reach them yeah i'll i'll work
on that you can grab the intestine
okay you're the boss you're the doctor
bus
it's fine it's fine it's fine if i gotta
grab these they're they boss doctor
the boss
hey
don't worry i'm just i like when you put
blood in maybe his arm's just moving
like that
he's like filling up like a balloon oh
yeah he's like three thousand nine all
right
all right all right let's put it in all
right now we gotta pull out the other
one
there we go i pulled it out oh his
other intestine fell out no other
intestine he won't need it how he won't
need bonus intestines
i can't reach it you put the other blue
one
it says it still needs uh
it's stuck i can't reach
there not like this not like this i need
another intestine oh no
no i i can grab it i can grab it i can
rub it i can rub it
okay oh my god how did you get it there
are you serious
all right all right i got a broom to
fish it out oh yeah
okay sorry
just oh it moved it moved it moved that
should be enough right
can you reach it doctor [ __ ] a movement
more
come on come on
come on ken you can do this come on come
on check it out
you're a sergeant you know find
precision with tools yes that's right i
do
broom teamwork make the dream work you
need some more light
i got you fam
that's the problem right you didn't have
enough little light in there there you
go
come on come out come on it's like we're
getting a rat out of there
you want to try
sweep that rat out how's he doing the
room is stuck
oh god he's like i gotta go get some
more blood for him
the room is stuck now god dang it
i think he's about to die doctor oh
doctor it's not looking too good doctor
oh god
syringe how's that
intestine going doctor oh intestines
oh yeah it's come like a spring flower
it's coming out maybe it's the barrel's
fault
you know what i mean maybe
okay okay i think i got a good grip here
actually so if you move
i almost get my if you move i can
it's just like i feel like i've done
this in my like
my this is what the married life is all
about right here come on you can get it
yeah yeah yeah we're not married ken
oh god uh all right yeah you got it you
got it you got it
you got it this is like when you try to
make a cobblestone generator
yes yes just like that and uh
and i already know how to make it but we
still spend two episodes trying to make
it
i i know how to make it more than you
know how to make it and we all
i think excuse me
it's excuse me
oh of course i can reach you
oh i know the problem i know the problem
you got to go sideways yeah i just try
to do that too
like you like kind of reach through the
wall there
get it i can see through my arm
amazing
all right all right you see i got a good
angle here
all right maybe if i can
i'm dead oh my god he has 800 left it's
fine
that's plenty of time that's plenty of
time trust me yeah you got this you got
this
come on [ __ ]
oh i got down to like 500. uh
there you go bro oh thanks i can see is
there not another one on the freaking
conveyor belt
i don't think it is no that's it oh god
oh there's another one right here in the
hollow bodies
well it is the cobblestone generator all
over again huh
oh my god get in there oh he's gonna
bleed dude
get in is that not oh oh my god we did
it
yeah one two three yeah yeah
catch us right here i mean roblox
oh seventeen
a new record that's my personal best
we did it i i'm i'm tired i'm gonna take
a break
yeah oh
that was fun though it was fun i hadn't
changed
handshake was worth it no we're good
we're good oh man i'm gonna take a break
17 [ __ ] minutes jeez are you still
there
i can't hear you i think i got some
weird glitch happening there
what the [ __ ]
i see you talking holy [ __ ]
a lot hello
what an end
what just happened
oh what the [ __ ] was that what happened
i don't know it like totally glitched
out everything
have you looked at you your other
options you got for your character now
uh [ __ ] i missed out on that i'm i'm i
messed up
you're so beautiful what why are you
looking it's a shame
i got a i got a smiley face bag on my
head and
a patient's gown and a lot of broken
legs and arms
but you were so beautiful when you were
burning up all right i was
it's not the same now it's not
you [ __ ] shot that was fun that was a
good time
yeah well are you going to keep
streaming
i am i mean i might as well stream for a
little while longer since i'm up doing
it
all right well check out ken stream i'm
going to head off
cinnamon toast ken twitch dot tv
oh yeah and check out sergeant simulator
2 it's hot on epic game store
epic it was fun it's epic yeah
uh all right i might go live later
today as well play some fall guys but uh
i need i need a break now i'm [ __ ]
tired
yeah yeah if you need anybody to play
with let me know i'm always around doing
nothing
i'll ping your mane later later
bye
oh wait i should have said bye to you
guys as well if i'm a girl
donating do i get recognized by beards
yes you did morgan thank you morgan
kaelin did you see journalists and
media's swedish bread video yes i did i
just recorded a video before this
uh reacting to it
uh all right thanks for joining guys
smash like subscribe it was fun uh
catch you next time i'm actually going
on holiday so i probably won't be live
uh for a week probably as in most
definitely
um
but um that's why i thought maybe i'll
go live again later today but it might
be a bit much because i have other
things to take care of before i go
but yeah get a couple days off it's
gonna be nice
i'm gonna miss you guys of course but
i'm still going to be uploading because
i'm headed a little bit on content
uh so yeah that's it thanks for joining
guys see you next time
yeah all right bye
you